one two three and four five six six
bullets swerving in fact he was hit
eight times but somehow perhaps because
he's only 24 he managed to survive but
his body his life is never going to be
the same no unlikely my own yes I
understand I got injured but the most
painful injury that I have is where I
got injured on my private parts I cannot
bear children anymore not even one kid
nothing he was in the front of the group
of striking miners running for their
lives in Marikana straight into the
police bullets more than a year on the
surviving strikers are still in their
teen shacks but the coleauxv can't work
he can boldly look after himself
and he and others are still fighting for
justice my legs can't carry me anymore
the only way I survive is to sit down
whatever I do I do while I'm sitting
when I stand up I have big problems
because my feet and my bones they cannot
carry me anymore since we fought for
better payment
nothing has changed the way we are
living is like slaves the Commission set
up to investigate has been beset with
problems it was due to take a few months
but nearly a year later is nowhere near
finished the state is paying for the
police legal team at top legal rates but
the inquiries now continuing without
legal representation for the miners
after the government refused to fund
their lawyers
the only option the miners seem to have
now is more protests zocalo travelled
with miners and supporters to
Johannesburg and vittatus around
university to try to get the attention
of a man who was once one of them a
miners leader now deputy president of
the ruling ANC party and amongst the
richest men in South Africa Cyril
Ramaphosa was invited to talk about
government plans but he was on the board
of Longman during last year's strikes
and massacre and is seen as a crater by
many miners now there's a lot of
bitterness still in Marikana Linda bian
Zao is among all those fat cats they
don't care about the blood that was
spilt in Marikana they don't care at all
they don't feel anything because their
lives are secure
what's dogs we must just die the
government of today the government of
Zuma
it doesn't care anymore for us they felt
no one was listening then during the
strikes they're still battling to have
their voices heard now Alex Crawford Sky
News Marikana